dass die letzten beiden male so mega gut
bei euch ankam habe ich mir gedacht da
gehen wir heute mal wieder gemeinsam auf
deutsch - als erstes sehen wir hier eine
normal heart beat eingeblendet dann
sehen wir einen dies hat wieder
eingeblendet und dann wenn deine mutter
vom 3
[Musik]
doch so eine scheiße geld fällt runter
wer findet daraus ansprüche die meinem
namen jeden tag dropped ich packe hier
ja nur kurz wird jetzt in der zeit
niemand die polizei rufen alle überhaupt
nicht aus dieser typische alba ich weiß
nicht aber wie stellt ihr euch so einen
typischen deutschen vor
vom aussehen ich würde sagen blond dünn
sean penn
albans doppelpunkt wir schenken uns
dieses jahr nichts zu weihnachten auch
ahlmann heiliger so war also wir haben
es in unserer familie dieses jahr
wirklich so gemacht dass wir uns
überhaupt nichts zu weihnachten
geschenkt haben und das haben auch fast
alle eingehalten aus meinem arm
habt ihr wahrscheinlich meiner instagram
story gesehen die hat mir ein ticket
geschenkt für einen puppentheater
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend ahlmann wenn der nachbar nach
22 uhr noch ein lärm machte einbauten
des mieters ist halt allerdings auch
wieder komplett die wahrheit und ich
weiß dass ich das in diesem video wieder
1000 mal sagen werde das ist komplett
die wahrheit ist und so weiter und so
fort aber auch hier so ich jetzt in
dieser wohnung hatte ich noch nicht so
richtig aber davor als wir noch so
richtig zur miete gewohnt habe in so
einer kleinen wohnung im gebäude wo
irgendwie 20 parteien drin waren da man
so viele leute so ich habe fieber
gespielt um halb elf oder so die dann
einen kraftraum entschuldigung können
sie bitte ein bisschen leiser auf die
tasten ihres controllers drücke ich
versuchen zu schlafen mit meinen 70
kinder und 60 mal ganz gut gegen dimitri
werfen immer verlässt den raum länger
als fünf minuten und kommt zurück
kálmáns doppelpunkt wir wollten gerade
eine vermisstenanzeige aufgeben das ist
auch wieder so die wahrheit das sind sie
diese typischen alm ansprüche apropos
ahlmann teams überhaupt die meisten
teams also wirklich irgendwie 80 90
prozent der liebste ich euch heute zeige
sind von der seite ahlmann unterstrich -
2.0 auf instagram ich habt ihr euch
unten verlinkt in der beschreibung also
schott gern mal vorbei da habe ich die
minis her und die post jeden tag solche
lustigen sachen auch mit lustigen
caption also eine mega meiste zeit sind
voller lohnt auf jeden fall ihren
ahlmann an die am 25 erst um 12 uhr
aufsteht h er lebt noch jedes mal jedes
jedes gottverdammte familientreffen ich
weiß nicht wie es bei euch ist aber bei
uns waren familientreffen sonst meine
omas opas auch alle gelebt haben waren
die alle immer so um 11 uhr und 11 uhr
am samstag oder sonntag ist für mich als
eine person die sehr sehr lange immer
wach ist und auch dann irgendwie von der
schule oder vom feiern keine ahnung was
ist für mich gefühlt noch mitten in der
nacht dann kommt man da an dann muss man
sich nicht
sprüche anhören lassen hat man
wahrscheinlich auch noch eine hose wohl
auch pattinson dann so ich stelle mich
ein bisschen kalt in die hose oder
rassistischen wir haben sie seit wochen
nicht saugen gehören bitte reinigen sie
ihre wohnung bevor mäuse kommen
gezeichnet ehepaar blabla erstes
obergeschoss und das ist wirklich sonst
hätte der der der kannten nur von
deutschen kommen das ist wirklich so
dass sie sich dann darüber beschweren
hey einerseits wenn sie saugen nach 22
uhr ist es zu laut aber sie müssen sagen
weil sonst könnte ja sein dass über ihre
wohnung neu sind unsere wohnung kommen
das ist wirklich deutschland in der
nacht schnell dass auch deutsche nation
ist es das hier wenn als großstadt
urlaub machen taxi fahren ehe sich mit
der s-bahn verfahren immer so meine mom
auch mal so
da waren wir relativ kleine wir waren in
münchen irgendwie meine mom meinte oder
man denkt meinte so ey das mit dem taxi
beruhig dich los war meinte auf jeden
fall ja nein wir müssen dem taxi fahren
voll unnötig geldverschwendung wenn ich
mir die bahn auf einmal weg wir waren da
in schwabing west im ghetto bliebe
kollegen anlässlich meines geburtstags
gibt es belegte brötchen in der kühe
ahlmann kollegen eine sekunde bestehe
nicht warum alle maße auch diese
belegten brötchen abfahren ich weiß nie
wie es bei euch in der schulzeit war
aber also arbeitszeit keine ahnung ich
habe jetzt irgendwie neuen ganzen leben
vielleicht ja inzwischen praktikas
gemacht also da war es halt irgendwie
auch nie so richtig der fall aber in der
schule was hat immer so wenn heute
geburtstag haben die alt muffins
mitgebracht oder kuchen oder so wie war
das bei euch da ist der süßigkeit oder
kuchen und salman annette wenn jemand
mit metallbesteck in der beschichteten
pfanne
das ist so denn beide bahn und leider
auch hundertprozentig es mir letztes mal
aufgefallen ahlmann annette wenn baby im
seidenmalerei kurs für ihr
schmetterlings hoch gelobt im nächsten
mai werden google suchvorschläge
verglichen von deutschland mit england
amerika und erst mal seht ihr das hier
also in amerika habe sich verändert ist
es wenn man einen gibt es da oft dann
kommen oft ein metal oder dragon fruit
und oben bei deutschland steht kokain
muttermilch menschenfleisch und quoten
alles klar dicker das kann eigentlich
gar nicht sein dass die deutschen so was
kugeln oder ahlmann annette wenn an die
an heiligabend um 22 uhr mit seinen
jungs locker diese seite das ist einfach
das ist pures gold und apropos pures
gold meine lieben freunde daran hat
nämlich das nächste mini zu tun und zwar
ist das hier echtes gold das hier ist
falsches gold aber ahlmann comedy colt
ist schütte pole und danke das ist
ich frag mich ob es auch in der
englischen sprache solche komischen
begriffe gibt zu dass anstatt dass sie
dann sagen wir welcome sagen die sowohl
welcome eine straße so steht die bühne
schon gewöhnt ganz kurze info eben kurz
bevor gleich das video direkt weiter
geht mit den ahlmann - ähm ich wollte
euch ganz kurz darüber in kenntnis
setzen dass soeben eine neue podcast
folge von den podcast von sander mir
namens dick und doof online gegangene
spotify auf apple podcast auf dieser auf
wer hat eigentlich podcast auf diese auf
jeden fall reden sahen darauf nicht über
schwule tiere über kloß in zügen über
sprachnachrichten von sandras mutter die
hören wir uns an
ich fass allgemeinen sind also ein
bisschen zusammen auch die alpaka
wanderung als will aber eine dreiviertel
stunde oder fast schon eine stunde war
gott und die welt einen links unten auf
jeden fall in der video beschreibung
klingt dort gern gleich nach dem video
drauf wenn ihr euch das anderen wollte
ich muss mal öfter atmen jetzt geht das
video auf jeden fall weiter wie man am
anfang
[Musik]
payback karte jedes mal wenn ich im rewe
oder keine ahnung welchen supermarkt ja
auch immer einkaufen bin immer so die ja
ja das war es ja haben sie eine payback
karte
nein nein hat irgendjemand eine payback
karte locker natürlich habe ich eine
playback haben das ist natürlich will
ich ja so viele punkte und jochen
schweizer und beschichteten fassen
kaufen beim arzt doppelpunkte
datenschutz bitte halten sie abstand
ahlmann hintertürchen
es ist aber wirklich so auch irgendwie
wenn man bei der bank ist oder im
bürgerbüro da so derzeit noch keinen
menschen
es ist doch scheißegal mal scheißegal ob
einer direkt hinter mir steht supermarkt
stopp verkauf von feuerwerk allmacht der
nächste bubi wieder ausrastet auf der
bühne das aber allgemein das ding so ich
checke nicht warum in deutschland alles
um mega krank feuerwerks basiert sind
also ja okay das ist jetzt nicht nur
deutschland zwar allgemein solche checks
den sind nicht klar als sieht mega schön
aus aber diese ganzen scheiß polenböller
und china pro tag einen menschen einfach
nur teuer laut und gefährlich da stimmt
lasst uns die rechnung einfach durch
vier teilen ahlmann sich hatte aber eine
brotscheibe weg
[Musik]
die sache ist die bilder an sich und
thermalen noch mal diesen spruch darüber
aber der spruch alleine wäre auch schon
witzig genug almanci sie sich davor
drücken die 50 cent in die kaffeekasse 1
so war es ist so war einfach hast du
eine zigarette für mich klar hier bitte
danke hast du auch feuer aber rauchen
kannst du selber oder bist du mir leid
es tut mir leid das ganze video besteht
nur daraus dass ich klatschen und lachen
allerdings zeige ich euch jetzt mal den
deutschen humus die pommersche feine
leberwurst und wenn man mal über
leberwurst nachdenken ist eigentlich so
ekelhaft das ist einfach gibt das ist
will ich gar nicht über nachdenken
ahlmann es an silvester
[Musik]
auch immer mit vor dieses dinner for one
gesetzt also die man diese show ist ja
irgendwie weiß nicht 10 tausend jahre
alt und sie so scheiße aber trotzdem
geben so alle ahlmann eltern voll darauf
ab und worauf auch alle einmal eltern
darauf ab geht es das hier und zwar in
die schüssel cages kosten ja auch aber
san francisco das ist neue liga bin
allerdings auch schon zum vorletzten
albani und zwar dass das hirn ahlmann an
die wie er sich versteckt vor der ersten
mahnung und der gez beitragsforderungen
und dann kommt mir jetzt auch schon zum
letzten deutschen ahlmann ihm für die
heutige episode und zwar ist es das hier
als wenn jemand vor silvester böller
[Musik]
so endet richtige brigitte und so ein
richtiger 13 an der stelle ich das heute
wieder ist allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn euch meine reaktion
auf diese deutschen ahlmann minus
gefallen hat dann würde ich mich sehr
über einen daumen hoch von euch unter
dem video ihr freund schreibt mir gern
irgend etwas lustiges unten in den
kommentaren denn ich wollte es jetzt
einzeln dass ich in meiner autos immer
den lustigsten kommentar vom vorigen
video rein packe
so schreibt ein witz oder irgendwas
lustiges oder keine ahnung was und dann
kommt ihr vielleicht weil weit auto
[Musik]